can he hit this young man that's the big
question and if you could you look at
those numbers you know that this is all
at the beginning of the season his last
three starts is he's been really good
and he got him with a fastball away
so it ended up being a long inning for
singer but he works around the two walks
austin
gomber who is making his 13th appearance
and just his third start yeah now he's a
he's not an overpowering left-hander
lifted in the air out to right center
and followed back can't come up with it
fantasy flying the second
and he's on his way to third he'll be
held up there
and it's a one out triple for monday
back to back walks to start the inning
so two on here's dylan carlson and he
gets it and drives it in the gap in
right center
one run is in
here comes another that's fowler
and dylan carlson brings in two
two to nothing cardinals on a double by
dylan carlson and again the 2-2 to
colton wong
lined base head into right center
and with that it's a three-nothing
cardinals lead on a 2-2 pitch colten
wong the single to drive in carlson
three-nothing cardinals
jammed now carpenter charges
and throws wild and goldsmith had to
make a diving play to
prevent another 90 feet
that was not an easy play for carpenter
and that very well
could be a hit for olivares
shallow center bader diving catch hoe
want to play
harrison banner in center field robs
bubba starling
oh what a play by bader
[Music]
full sprints racing in and robs bubba
starling
[Applause]
hart hit the right field and comes
fowler and he makes the play slides and
makes the play takes it right off the
grass and takes a hit away from here
as carlson goes down to get it extra
bases again dylan
who has a double tonight on his way to
second base
why not a triple dylan carlson to third
with a triple standing up
[Applause]
first and third
edmond ground ball
out there back to first and safe and the
run will score
and that'll make it a four nothing st
louis lead as carlson scores
they're going to take a look at it but
lopez got rid of that thing quickly you
know the cannon that monday has very
close
well the hope is at this point
it's too close to overturn
this should be a quick call here
and the call is out
so they turn the double play it's
overturned and the cardinals with a
leadoff triple do not score
the 01 pitch
and that is a base hit inside the first
base line off the sidewall and an extra
base hit for paul goldschmidt
on base for the second time tonight
go along with the walk dan so two down
runner at second the batter is
brad miller they're d.h tonight
left-handed hitter he's walked and
grounded out
the one-two
and miller hits it down into the corner
and right and that ball is down
the cardinals do get that key two-out
hit miller at second base in there
safely and scoring its goldschmidt and
they add to their lead
brad miller driving in paul goldschmidt
he went down to get it it's four nothing
the 2-2 pitch
carlson base hit three for three and now
a home run away from the cycle
he's got the double the single
the triple and a home run away from the
cycle that sets up tommy edmond he's
looking to get the ball in the air and
extend the cardinal lead it's four
nothing right now in the sixth the kick
and the pitch a swing and there's a fly
ball that's hit to deep right center
field and it's caught in front of the
track by bubba starling tagging at third
carlson scores on to third harrison
bader and the cardinals lead 5-0 in the
six
[Applause]
diving stop carpenter gets up oh what a
play matt carpenter
the diving stop the third base line and
a strike to goldschmidt to rob
salvador perez
gomber loving it his defense has been
sensational tonight
there's a rope into center
colt long a two hit night on base for
the third time two hits and a walk
and a ground ball
six four can they turn
nope
they'll get the lead man
can't get the double play
the speed of tommy edmond
there's a base hit to right field for
franco he is one for four and that's
that high fastball that he loves
anything up there a 3-2 pitch again by
jake woodford outside corner and he
struck him out the game comes to a close
the cardinals shut out the royals five
nothing and they take game two well you
got yourself a complete ball game that
man right there with three hits the
double the triple a single the other way
austin gomber was fantastic the bullpen
sealed the deal and the cardinals even
up the series